sometimes in my life I'm like oh my
freakin good
what is good and I feel like that's what
my instagrams like today all this
awkward guys are gonna learn how to
finally pose like Instagram model the
only times I've ever tried to be a model
I'm wearing like at least two GoPros I
got like the sorority handout basically
we have one pose get close to a window
with good lighting and raising my
eyebrow kind of like this that's the
only thing that I know how to do when I
was in Disneyland I should be more
excited but literally the picture is a
white picture of me standing like this
and it's like the most miserable picture
if someone whips out a camera my go-to
pose is just my hand in my pocket and
then just like a cheesy smile they look
like they have their life together
they're always on the street on the go a
lot of them do that hashtag OOTD
Instagram bloggers are usually really
stylish and they're always looking off
into the distance contemplating life
kind of remind me of Ryan Gosling
I think Instagram fashion bloggers make
their lives look a lot better than they
actually are they make it look easy
but I'm sure it's a lot harder and more
complicated today we have Davey and
Instagram photographer teaching us how
to pose so there are only a handful of
poses that Instagram fashion models do
three poses are casually the mid walk
adjusting your clothes clothes number
one is a casual lead so basically it's
just to show that you're relaxed while
showing off your clothes cleaning was a
bit of a challenge because I feel like I
don't want to look like I was
uncomfortable at first to be honest it
felt really forced and I was kind of
like oh I'm not sure I'm not gonna like
those and it showed in the photos was
out and I was actually leaning like
weighting it actually felt natural and
it looked natural
the whole experience was very
uncomfortable from like where to put my
feet where to put my hands where should
I lean how to pull my jacket how to
everything was just like it looked very
uncomfortable it's weird because your
arms sometimes was squished and you
didn't know it or like it felt natural
but then like your shoulders are
underlined this pose is very awkward
nothing felt natural to me I just kind
of did what they told me to do it was
awkward did not feel
doing that I actually flatlined a little
bit to figure out which leg I was
putting in front and it's actually
pretty hard where's number two it's
gonna be at the meet walk basically
you're just gonna be walking and look
like you're going somewhere but you're
not actually going anywhere when I was
looking off I was just thinking like
what am I thinking about but that really
like translates into an awesome photo
because you see the photo and it just
looks like hmm what am I thinking about
I felt super awkward not good at walking
in my normal life so doing it on camera
was even worse it kind of forces me to
come out of my element in my shell
because I feel like it's easy to take
one where no one's watching is it weird
that actually enjoy it just the act of
moving was really awkward for me I don't
know why I'm also just dressed up to the
nine and like this is not who I am this
is really hard like pretending to walk
is harder than actually walking you kind
of forget how to walk it didn't feel as
awkward as I thought it would be
especially after seeing all the guys do
it people were definitely looking
because we are all dressed up but we
were all together they made it much
easier
hey Justin your clothes she was there
your fashion also it looks like you're
thinking about your clothes all you want
to do is just look good it's funny
because there's only so many things that
guys can do you can either button a
jacket fix your tie and that's it I feel
like I really enjoyed playing with the
watch code you know we always see those
photos of their like or some reason if
something's always wrong with our
country I like it it's simple very happy
that it did this I feel like I'm
learning so much I didn't know what to
do with my hands and that was really
uncomfortable
I mean I think I'd be very good without
arms the poses that I enjoyed the most
were ones where it involved a lot of
accessories I think I got to hide behind
things and it made me feel like it
wasn't really about me but it was more
so about the look
I was actually surprised I'm kind of
awkward person I didn't expect to feel
goodbye so the pictures and was like oh
that's not that bad I'd hit that
after I posted the photos my light game
was up at least over 100 huge difference
for me my highest liked photo was the
one where I was walking and like fixing
an item of clothing 182 likes they're
hitting over like 300 pretty solid
increase of over a hundred on each of
these photos this one particular picture
where I'm fake walking 314 likes
I had 413 likes and over 28 comments the
comments were oh my goodness
nice the praying hand damn are you
famous now there's more life than being
really really really ridiculously
good-looking damn dad oh my god
ba-ba-boom these last two photos I was
hesitant to post cuz I didn't think I
looked the greatest in them I posted
them and they both put up great numbers
my light game and it actually did make
me feel more confident about having a
bald head now when I had nice photos of
it you're like oh you know I can rock it
you're also really quick to pick out
your own flaws those might not beat it I
just might be in your own head and like
other people aren't gonna see that
before I had no idea what to do with my
hand or even smile now that I know like
if I just look like this like that is
the pose every time I had so many people
like text me why is your watch always
broken
[Music]